[APPLAUSE]
JEREMIAH HARMSEN: Thank you.
All right, good
morning, everyone.
And hello to everyone
watching on the stream.
My name is Jeremiah Harmsen.
I am an engineer here in Zurich.
I lead our applied
machine intelligence team.
Our general mission is to
advance the impact of machine
learning here in
Zurich, across Google,
and throughout the world.
So why are we here in Zurich?
I want to take a
few minutes to talk
about why Zurich is
the hub of AI research
for Google in Europe.
So the Zurich office is actually
one of our oldest offices
in Europe.
It's one of our largest
engineering offices.
It's the largest one
outside the States.
And similarly, our
research center
here is the largest
one outside the States.
And those two really
play off each other.
So the product teams, they have
all these really interesting
challenges to solve.
And the research teams
work hand-in-hand with them
to solve them.
So as a researcher,
this is fantastic.
We get to build all these
things and immediately
impact billions of lives,
whether it's through Chrome,
or Gmail, or YouTube.
So this is a really
natural place to do that.
We've got a lot of great
universities with ETH ad EPFL.
We have a number of programs
where we support and work
with researchers there.
We also have a growing
fundamental research group
here.
We have a Brain team that
is growing very quickly.
They look at things like
reinforcement learning,
artificial neural networks,
and general optimization
and some adversarial networks.
So really quickly, I want to
highlight some of the work
that teams across
Google do in research.
The first is the
handwriting team.
So this team takes
a bunch of squiggles
across a bunch of
different services
and turns them into words,
whether it's on a watch
or on your phone.
This team uses technology to
build a really neat web app
called Quick, Draw!
Has anyone used Quick, Draw!
before?
All right, a few folks.
I think I found the Googlers.
[LAUGHTER]
I highly recommend
trying this out.
This is a lot of fun.
This is where you get to draw.
And the machine tries to
guess what you're drawing,
whether it's a helicopter
or an ice cream cone.
So this has been a lot of fun.
But it's also been a really
interesting source of doodles.
We've gotten over
a billion doodles
from 100 different countries.
And we've released this
as a dataset, which
is really interesting for
people, to researchers
at Google, and outside
Google to comb through.
So for instance, here is OK--
so for instance,
here's what a chair
looks like as drawn by
different countries.
And it's interesting
because you can see,
some countries in general draw
it a little bit differently.
So this might come
up a little bit later
as we talk about biases in data.
For instance, we can
see some countries
may prefer a little bit of an
ISO view or things like that.
And so what happens if we leave
them out of our training data?
And what happens when we try to
classify a chair that's maybe
drawn from one of
these places where
we don't have as much data?
Another really great product
is from the sense team here.
This team is really
at the forefront
of putting machine
learning on device.
This one in particular
is called Now Playing.
This gives you an
ambient superpower
where you always know
what song is playing.
This runs in the background.
And this is a really
challenging problem.
Right?
Because we don't want to
suck everyone's battery down.
It also has some really
interesting privacy
implications.
This model runs
completely on device.
It doesn't send
any data to Google.
So I think this is a really
interesting direction we're
going to see a lot more of.
So from the same team is
one of my favorite uses
of machine learning.
So this is Smart Text Selection.
I'm sure everybody has tried
to select text on their phone.
You have this
frustrating experience
of trying to drop the two little
blue pins with your thumbs.
I have kind of big thumbs.
It's especially awkward for me.
This is actually a
machining learning
model that runs on the device.
So when you touch
a piece of text,
it does a search to figure
out what you're touching.
If you touch a phone
number, it automatically
selects it for you.
If you touch an address,
it automatically
selects the address for you.
And again, this is a
model that runs on device.
It doesn't need to
send data to Google.
And I think this
is a great example
of improving one of those
little frustrations for users.
The last thing I'll
mention is that we
work on the tools
that are open source.
I really wanted to put a slide
of what we're working on.
Unfortunately, it
hasn't been released.
So I encourage everyone to
watch the TensorFlow developer
summit a week from Friday.
The team from
Zurich will be there
and announcing what we've been
working on for the last year.
All right, that was
a very quick tour.
I am excited that everyone
is here in Zurich.
And I'm excited to
hear the speakers.
So with that, I'd like to
move on to Fernanda and Jess.
[APPLAUSE]
FERNANDA VIÉGAS: Thank you.
Thanks.
Hi, everyone.
I'm so excited.
This is the first
PAIR UX symposium.
As Matt and Lucia
were saying before,
we had the first
symposium last year.
And it was a general symposium.
This is the first focused
symposium around UX.
And I think that matters
a lot because if we
want to think
seriously about AI,
and how it affects
people's lives,
and how users
interact with AI, we
need to be thinking from a
user experience perspective.
And so that's why today
is really important.
So I'm Fernanda Viégas.
JESS HOLBROOK:
Does this one work?
Oh, hey.
Hey, I'm Jess Holbrook.
FERNANDA VIÉGAS: And we're going
to talk a little bit about PAIR
So Jess and I and
Martin Wattenberg,
who couldn't be here today,
launched PAIR last year,
middle of last year.
And this is really
the first time
there was an initiative
at Google for People + AI
research, and again,
trying to bring
these different
perspectives to the table,
so design thinking,
HCI, how do we
build ML systems
that are designed
with user needs in mind
from the beginning,
from the very objective
function that you design.
How do you design an
objective function that
takes into account user needs?
So when we talk
about People + AI
research, who are the people?
That's a question we get a lot.
So who are the people
you're talking about?
We're talking about
a range of people.
hardcore machine
learning researchers
and engineers.
What are the tools that they
need to develop better machine
learning systems?
If you've been
programming for a while,
you probably know that
traditional development tools
are not exactly designed
for machine learning.
So we're going to talk
a little bit about this.
So what kind of tool do we need?
And then a different kind of
user is the user in the middle
here, where we talk about
augmented expert intelligence.
So imagine professionals
who are going
to be interacting with
machine-learning-enabled
systems at a professional
level, at an expert level.
But they are not themselves
machine learning experts.
Right?
So you can think about
doctors, designers, architects,
musicians.
How do you actually partner
with an intelligent system
in a meaningful, productive way?
So these are some of the
things we're studying in PAIR.
And then finally, all the way
to the right here, this notion
of AI for everyone.
So even if you are a lay
user, you are potentially-- so
imagine a situation.
You were a YouTube viewer.
And you were being recommended
the next video for you
to watch.
Maybe there's
something where you
want an explanation about why
you were recommended a video.
Those kinds of questions
about explainability,
trust, how do we surface some
of what the machine learning
systems are doing in
the backhand for users
are also research questions
we're looking into.
There's a whole host
of research questions
that I think
permeate all of this
that have to do with fairness
also that we're looking into.
So when we talk
about People + AI,
it's a whole range of people
and users we have in mind.
And so finally,
what does PAIR do?
We've been very busy.
We do a lot of different
kinds of things.
So one of the things
I'm very excited about
is the first column
here on the left,
where we get to open
source tools and platforms.
And so this is the place where
we take a lot of the things
that we're actually
doing at Google, tools
that we're using internally at
Google that are very helpful,
and we externalize them.
We open source them.
And that makes me very happy.
And so I'm very quickly
going to talk about that.
We also create
educational materials.
And these are for the lay user.
These are not for experts.
We publish and we have
academic publications.
We are sharing best practices.
We run symposia.
We have visiting faculty.
We give out faculty grants.
So there's a whole host of
ways in which we interact
with the broader community
around this notion of human-AI
interaction.
And then, as I was
saying, one of the things
that gives me great
joy is that we
get to open source
tools like Facets.
So Facets is a
visualization that
allows you to look at
your training data.
Again, one of those gaps in
machine learning tooling--
your data is super important.
How do you look at it?
How do you debug your data?
And so tools like
Facets allow you
to do that in a much
more effective way.
And it's been really great
to see how Facets gets used
by people outside of Google.
So for instance, this woman, Joy
Buolamwini from the MIT Media
Lab, used Facets in her
research to look into fairness
and how different
facial recognition
APIs deal with different
races, for instance,
and different genders.
And so, again, it's great to
see how these tools make it
out there, and how they're being
used for very serious research
work.
Another focus of research
for us is just fairness.
And we've done a
number of things here.
So released tools, so this
is Facets that you saw.
The one that's
animating here is called
embedding projector, which
allows you to visualize
massively high-dimensional
spaces, which is super
useful in machine learning.
We've also worked
with Creative Labs
to create an introductory video
on what is machine bias, what
is bias in machine learning.
There are obviously
publications.
This one here, I'm
very excited about.
So that everybody knows what I'm
talking about, this one here.
Can you see my cursor?
OK, great.
So this one here was
kind of different.
We actually translated a
highly mathematical paper
around definitions of
machine learning fairness
into a visualization that
people could play with,
a simulation around
a bank giving out
loans for different
kinds of populations.
OK?
And one of the things that
was really interesting
was to talk about the fact that
there are different definitions
of fairness, and you need to
choose a definition of fairness
to implement in your system.
Unfortunately,
mathematically speaking,
you can't put all the
definitions of fairness
together in one system.
So you're always going
to have to choose,
how are you going to be fair.
Right?
And so the reason
why I call this out
is that it was a
simple visualization,
a simple simulation,
and it went viral.
And part of the
reason was that it
created this much more
accessible way of turning
these mathematical equations
into something that people
could play with, and could
understand, and could
start to see the tradeoffs.
And so we got a lot
of emails from places
like criminal justice
systems in the US asking us,
oh, could I create
a visualization
like this to try to understand
fairness within my own context.
And so again, I think
it speaks to the need
of having ways of
broadening the message
and involving other stakeholders
into this bigger debate of what
it means to have these
machine learning systems
and how they interact
with society as a whole.
The other thing I want
to point out very quickly
is we also launched
deeplearn.js,
which is this really exciting
machine learning open source
library that brings
ML to the web.
And that matters why?
Because it means it
lowers the barriers.
You don't have to
download anything.
install anything.
It's JavaScript-based,
so it means
it opens up machine learning to
a whole new host of developers.
It runs on your browser.
It runs on your phone.
It runs locally.
You're not sending
information anywhere else
to any one service.
So it's been great to see how
people have been using it.
So Alex Chen, who is going
to speak later today,
is going to talk about
a teachable machine that
used deeplearn.js.
Another group in
Brain, Magenta, used
it to create music
online to let you partner
with this
machine-learning-enabled
jamming session called
Performance RNN.
We have people here
in the house who--
so we have Dan Shiffman.
Where are you?
Dan?
OK, go talk to Dan afterwards.
So Dan is a faculty
member at NYU
and is creating this entire
GitHub repository called ml5js,
which is basically the friendly
machine learning for the web
that you see here.
This is Dan's work and
his students' work.
And so the idea, again, is to
use something like deeplearn.js
to broaden the reach of machine
learning, just in the sense
to bring folks who may
not have been able to work
with these systems, outside
of places like Google
or other academic
institutions that are
very computer-sciencecentric.
But how do you broaden it?
How do you bring it to
a much bigger audience?
So Dan Shiffman is
doing this work.
There is also a whole undergrad
class going on right now at MIT
that uses deeplearn.js
so that students can just
start building as soon as
possible with machine learning.
And I'm going to stop here.
JESS HOLBROOK: Yeah, thank you.
I'm going to expand on what
Fernanda was saying there.
One of the things
that really gets
me excited about PAIR and about
the field in general right
now is this idea of
expanding the conversation,
and expanding who's included in
the work that we're doing here,
and seeing how this is
starting to manifest.
So one of the stories is--
I think it was two
or three weeks ago,
this guy named Oz started
tweeting about deep learning,
about how he was learning
deeplearn.js to--
the problem that
he wanted to solve
was that he wanted to help his
friend who had had a stroke
and is paralyzed be able
to navigate the web.
And so how he was
doing it is he was
trying to build a Chrome
extension using deeplearn.js
to allow his friend to
navigate the web with his eyes.
There's a link here.
Let's click it because it's
pretty cool if you see it.
And we started forwarding
this around on our team.
Alex also reached out to Oz.
I think one of the more
interesting parts of Oz's story
is Oz is homeless.
So he's a homeless
veteran in Portland
who sleeps in a homeless
shelter at night.
And he goes to the library,
and he codes on deeplearn
during the day because
he wants to allow people
with physical disabilities like
his friend access to the web.
Last week, we called Oz,
kind of talked to him
about what he wants to get done.
We're looking at ways
we can partner with him.
I've actually kind
of randomly been
thinking about Oz these
last couple of days.
It's not lost on me that
I'm traveling halfway
around the world for a
conference in Zurich,
in the room that we're in now.
And Oz, it's nighttime on
the West Coast right now.
So Oz is sleeping in a
homeless shelter right now.
But he's going to wake
up, and contribute,
and try to make the world
a better place in the way
that he wants to, with some
of the things that we're
building right here.
And this is really,
really inspiring to me.
Right?
I think we're getting at
this inclusion and people
being able to solve their
own problems with AI
from many different angles.
So this is just pretty
amazing stuff to see.
And I'd recommend everyone
follow him because he's
a guy on a mission.
And so I think there's going to
be a lot more to come from Oz.
Another thing that
we've been working
on for the last 18
months or so is something
that we call AIY Projects.
So this is something that
I was on until December.
And this is really about
bringing AI to the maker
and probably going to extend
into the STEM communities.
So if you haven't
seen these before,
remember the little
cardboard VR goggles
we did a couple of years ago?
It's kind of like
that but for AI
in a bunch of different ways.
These little kits, if you
already have a Raspberry Pi,
are pretty cheap.
They're like $20.
I think the vision
kit is like $45.
And so we have two-- one
that really focuses on audio,
so audio input and output,
and one that is a camera.
So it focuses on recognition.
One of the really cool
things about the camera
is it does it all on device.
So all the models run on device.
This is something that's
come up a couple of times
so I wanted to just put a
little extra emphasis on it,
especially for the people
that aren't from Google,
is that we're investing a lot.
And you'll hear a lot about
everything running on device,
not sending anything
to the cloud,
not making that a
requirement for people
to get the benefits of AI.
I don't have it here.
But one of the tweets from
our original launch that
really inspired me was this dad
posted a tweet with his kid.
And he said, "Just did our first
electronics project together."
And they built our kit.
And what blew my mind is that
kid's orientation towards what
an electronics project is
is that it has AI in it.
The first thing he
put together, he
was building, and
controlling, and using AI
to do what he wanted it to do.
That's a mind-blowing
generational shift
that I hope that we can actually
put a lot more pressure on.
And if people don't feel an
intimidation, or an otherness,
or like, oh, I'm worried
about this thing,
but helping them control it from
nine years old and on, I think,
is a big shift in the
mindset that we can make.
We also reach very fancy people.
So this is Martin testifying
before the House of Commons
on the Science and
Technology Committee,
where he broke out
his best suit and tie.
And so actually
talking to people
about algorithmic
decision-making
and helping to try to inform a
lot of these very big and very
important policy debates
through people that
are on the ground trying
to make this work so
we have the right
policies around the world.
And then we're also doing a
ton to try to reach as much
of the UX community as we can.
So just a little while
ago, through a lot
of effort of Josh
Lovejoy and others,
we launched a Google
Design collection really
focused on HAIR and what
we call the UX of AI.
So we're trying to get as many
of our resources up and out
here.
We don't really talk
about unreleased stuff
or stuff we do internally.
But this came out of a
lot of internal efforts
that we'd done around trying
to educate and mobilize
the UX community at
Google to really own
what is the UX of AI, and what
does this next wave of user
experience we want to create.
And so we're trying
as rapidly as we
can to get as much
of this external
as well because it's a thing
that's a lot bigger than Google
and a lot bigger than a small
group at Google, for sure.
And so with that, I've been
thinking about this, like how
to put a wrapper on what--
Fernanda and I get the
question a lot of times
like, what is PAIR doing?
Or why does PAIR exist?
Or what is our purpose here?
And one of the ways
I put it sometimes
is, I think we're
making human-centered
AI the easiest option.
And I think that there's
two big parts there.
I think one of the
big parts is we're
trying to define what
human-centered AI is.
We're trying to define that
through a big conversation
with a lot of people, and
a lot of different groups,
and companies, and
technologists, and academics,
and everything like that.
And so we're really
trying to define
what we think that means
with all these improvements.
And then as a user researcher,
I'm a big believer in people
do the easiest
thing, not the thing
they're most motivated to do.
So we're looking
for ways of, how
do we make that
human-centered approach
to AI the easiest option.
How do we put tools, and
resources, and trainings,
and options, and everything
in people's hands
so that if they are
on board with us
and they want to do
this human-centered AI
thing that it's the easiest
option for them to do it.
And with that, I think we're
going to really push that
into the conversation
and into the world
through products that we build.
And with that, I think
it's time to move on
to the pretty great
speaker lineup we have.
This is our hashtag,
if you care to tweet.
I think that's it.
All right, let's get going.
[APPLAUSE]